brolo Lucifer and queen oito of the
kakin Empire are related not only that
but their brother and sister related so
like really related this would make 14th
Prince wobble crawler's niece and it
would also make future family gatherings
incredibly awkward because new uncle
krapika is responsible for killing two
of Uncle krolow's best friends primarily
due to the fact that Uncle krolow
brutally kill murdered Uncle karapika's
entire clan for the purpose of selling
their body parts to third Uncle saridnik
that's right we have triple Uncle action
Happening Here in a situation that the
Spanish would refer to as a classic la
bataya de Los Tres dios extranos I know
it sounds stupid not Spanish the theory
all Hunter Hunter theories sound stupid
out of context there is no exception
feitan is a zoldek paristan is a Sheila
kilua is part cat person from The Dark
Continent they're all mind-numbingly
dumb until you hear the evidence and
this is no exception so let's see how it
works in chapter 350 eighth queen of the
kakin Empire oito reveals that she was
born in extreme poverty with four
siblings who too older and too younger
however King NASA B discovered oito and
became enamored with her while more
accurately his little nasubin became
enamored with her and then he whisked
oito away for a life of luxury however
we see a brief flashback of oito's Home
featuring three obscured children who
look shockingly similar to The Phantom
troop flashback in chapter 102 wearing
the same style of outfits one of whom is
thought to be crawler this is helped by
the common assertion that meteor city is
likely very close to the kakin Empire
and that we've even seen potential
evidence of seradnik's tattoo artist
abducting children from meteor City in
addition to this Ito and crolo look
stunningly similar featuring the same
eyes the same hair color and most
importantly both possess a naturally
genius level of intellect now as we know
crawler grew up to be something of a
naughty boy conducting some genocide
here and there thus starting krapika on
his path and the two are now converging
once again with karapika rather
fatesomely becoming The Bodyguard of
crawler's alleged sister and alleged
niece with the aim of protecting both
from yet another naughty Uncle for
Prince saradnik that's the general gist
of things and I think it's fun though if
it were true it creates this superb
drama because it puts krapika in this
almost Shakespearean style scenario you
know the whole I have been charged to
protect the family of the man who
murdered my family so there's a lot of
potential for some nice full circle
narrative because I've often thought
that even with this idea put to one side
the succession war is going to culminate
with karapika making a decision and that
decision is either going to be giving in
to Vengeance and taking revenge for his
dead Clan or managing to escape the
cycle and prioritizing the future of the
living AKA little baby wobble and a
relation to crawler would make that
choice much more powerful and the great
thing about something like this is that
the characters themselves don't ever
necessarily need to find out so many
great tragedies Bank on the idea that
only the audience has the full
information so on the one hand krapika
has reached the end of his quest with
radnik all he needs to do is recover the
remaining eyes and his life's purpose is
fulfilled so perhaps there will be a
classic situation where karapika can
only choose to save one either the eyes
or the baby again it's a lovely idea and
I think it's a great Avenue to really
dig deeper into crawler as well as
directly bring him into the meat of the
succession War but how sound is the idea
to start with the inciting instant let's
examine these two flashback panels a bit
closer with the Phantom Troop One in
particular this was something of an
enigma for many many years until chapter
396 Finally Revealed that these three
figures running with the tape are indeed
crolo Franklin and shell knock in both
panels the kids are dressed very similar
and it could be some sort of Epic
Togashi foreshadowing connection but in
reality two of the kids are dressed very
differently the one who would represent
Franklin has long sleeves and the child
representing shell knock I believe is
actually a little girl wearing a dress
however the crawler child matches both
of them well enough meaning that we
could say no this may not be the truth
but this could be crolo's original
family all of the siblings at oito
mentioned I mean yes it's a big stretch
but it's far from the biggest problem
with the theory because something else
this idea leans pretty heavily on is
that the karkin Empire is quite close to
meteor City and therefore easy to pick
up people kind of like going down to
your local human grocery store and this
is because in my opinion one of
togashi's greatest weaknesses as an
author is depicting space and time he is
phenomenal with characters and Concepts
however the reality of the world is
something often ignored and it can lead
to misconceptions like the following the
cocky Empire is often connected to
meteor City because we actually first
visit the Empire at the beginning of the
Chimera antarct it's where a company
takes gone and kilowattamukai who was
hired by kakin to conduct ecological
Research into their native significantly
smaller and much more manageable Chimera
ants the really big ants of course ended
up in NGL and then shortly after zazan
and some of the others take up residents
in meteor City so the logic here is that
karkin is close to NGL which is close to
meteor City and in the manga gone kilua
and kite do travel from khakin to NGL in
a couple of pages so it does give the
impression that they're right next door
but they're actually on completely
different sides of the world because the
Queen's arm was found south of York new
city which is the European continent
meanwhile kakin is on the Asia continent
and given that Chimera ant outbreak was
restricted to this bottom left sector of
the world it's safe to assume that
meteor city is also on the orbian
continent and therefore nowhere near
kakin is this a problem for the theory
not really Medio City's location doesn't
matter because it's still a Global Hub
people travel there from all over the
human realm to engage in all sorts of
illicit activities whether that's
kidnapping children or sourcing wives in
fact one of the most prominent cases of
wife sausage comes from the zodic family
kikiyo zoldik was originally a resident
to meteor City before she was selected
to marry into the Assassin family
furthermore the zeldick employees goto
and Canary were also acquired from
meteor City the reason why I imagine
this is a good idea is because for
people in Desperate situations their
loyalty is pretty cheap characters like
goto and Canary would and have given
their lives for the Zodiac family due to
their simple Act of elevating their own
Lifestyles and the same can be said of
cartoon queens in fact whether it's
mediocity or not this exact thing did
happen for Oita nasibi found her in a
slum best described as somewhere and I
don't see it as too far of the question
for him to have taken a trip to Medio
City to go people shopping a slightly
trickier concept is proving any sort of
blood connection between crolo and Oita
because yes they do look alike however I
don't like using Aesthetics to prove
anything it's mostly important to
mention to highlight the fact that they
don't look radically different and just
not related at all but other than that
what hits me a lot harder is how much
they share intelligence crolo is
obviously one of the greatest minds of
the series and oito all things
considered is not far off in fact oito's
introduction into the series was
tricking karapika into thinking that he
was actually meeting with ninth Prince
hulkenberg oito fooled carapica like
fooled him good that's a very
understated achievement and throughout
the war she has been consistently sharp
recognizing that during the meeting with
Zhang lay the krapika's explanation of
nen was much more for her benefit than
for his and even pinpointing with
terrifying accuracy kropica's intentions
with Prince redneck on one occasion even
questioning his strategic motives by
saying start with saraynik is that for
your convenience the fact that we had no
education education and a lifetime of
poverty oito is still this
intellectually gifted is wild and it's
much more solid connection to crawler
than fictional ascetics however for this
to work we would probably need to
imagine that crolo is the older brother
and we do know that he is somewhere
between 28 to 29 years old we also know
that his height is 177 centimeters tall
and he weighs 68 kilograms which
according to the BMI calculator makes
him a very very healthy boy meanwhile
oito's age is unknown and we don't know
exactly how old wobble is either however
if I were to guess then I would say
young mostly due to the whole being a
baby thing this is important because it
means that oito would have been
recruited for General cleanliness fairly
recently in the grand scheme of things
and therefore if any of this was true
would still have been a resident in
meteor city as recently as one or two
years ago which makes things a bit less
believable because crolo is depicted as
an orphan in all Phantom troop flashback
media I guess it's never explicitly
stated but it is heavily implied or at
the very least it would be quite the
retcon for him to have had like three
sisters and a brother for this entire
time so the idea would then need to
become that crolo is not one of oito's
four known siblings and perhaps he's an
estranged older child that was dumped in
meteor City by their parents for
whatever reason maybe they couldn't take
care of him maybe they sold him then
whatever it happened and then his
eventual siblings still grew up in
poverty but not like meteor City levels
of poverty and at this point I'd also
like to briefly Linger on the very first
panel we see of Queen oyter absolutely
beautifully drawn by Togashi you can
really sense the desperation and Terror
on her face but what captures my eye
even more is the framed portrait of King
NASA be in the background when I first
saw this I went hang on a second I I
know that image and it's because it's a
blatant copy paste from chapter 340
where nasabi gives his big dark
consonant speech which makes sense from
a manga making perspective because
tagashi's Health only gives him so much
ability to draw so reusing images isn't
quite as taboo as many mangaka often
view it but from an inward perspective
it's pretty funny because it means that
that picture was printed and framed
within like a day King nasabi saw
himself on the 10 television and said
damn I look good have that picture
framed and sent one to each of my eight
wives so that they can also appreciate
my Majesty which isn't too hard to
believe coming from a man who televised
himself on a blimp which I refer to as
the NASA blimp and weirdly enough it
actually quite suits him because his
natural figure greatly resembles a blimp
as it is alright sorry for the tangent I
have just never had any reason to talk
about that and I had to get it out but
let's get slightly more serious because
to me the be-all and end-all of this
idea really comes down to togashi's
connection with poverty as much as
Hunter Hunter has radically changed as a
series throughout the last two decades
tagashi does stay consistent with a
handful of themes one of which is the
commentary on Extreme wealth and extreme
poverty after a certain point most darks
in the series contain a core element of
wealth and equality such as York you
city with the hyper wealthy mafia
families engage in all sorts of unsavory
body part dealing versus the come from
nothing Phantom Troupe meanwhile the
entirety of Greed Island is set into
motion by a multi-billionaire who learns
that all of the money in the world
couldn't buy the 1 thing that he truly
wanted during the Chimera and talk we
have very obvious commentary with the
political structure of escorto and the
dictator Ming jolik and now the karkin
Empire well that should be pretty
obvious as well all of that was a very
long way of saying that Togashi has very
strong ideas about wealth and equality
and as a result he often portrays
poverty he portrays it a lot and he
generally does it exactly the same way
every time for example there's a lesser
known theory that Leorio and benault are
from the same town because they're
flashbacks in the 2011 anime show them
wearing very similar clothing and being
in the same dystopian poor environment
essentially the exact same evidence that
we're using for crawler's connection to
oito and that's because when Togashi
draws poverty he's not focused on
depicting exactly where that poverty is
happening he's more focused on conveying
the feeling the location itself doesn't
matter it's the state of being and
sotogashi has developed a very standard
aesthetic which generally involves
children wearing light scruffy clothes
usually shorts in bare Barren
environments it almost look quite
desert-like and each and every time he
depicts a new location of poverty they
are always essentially interchangeable
with one another it could all be one
place maybe it's all just mediocity but
it's more likely that these are all
separate places joined by togashi's
preferred depiction of poverty in fact
gyro is another example of this his
poverty backstory location is completely
indistinguishable from anyone else we've
mentioned and what's more interesting is
that specifically Oreo Theory doesn't
even work because his hometown was never
depicted in the manga what we see in the
2011 anime is their interpretation of
leoro's childhood which I find funny
because it means that what they did was
just lift from togashi's signature
poverty style so how much real meat is
there on the krollo oito relation well
I'd say about a chicken wing enough meat
to chew on and enjoy but nowhere near
enough meat like thoroughly satisfy
which is why you always need a pile of
wings One Wing does not do it it's
entirely possible but it relies on
questionable evidence and a lot of
convoluted connections and the main
reason why I think some people buy it is
less because of the actual evidence
available and more because of the future
potential I genuinely love the idea of
karapika ending up saving crawler's
family whether it was intentional enough
on but I also love the situation as it's
currently set up now not everything
needs to connect and what I really like
about Hunter Hunter is that it doesn't
have small world syndrome it's not Star
Wars where everything ends up being
connected to a Skywalker in some way
shape or form meaning yes you do have
your family dynasties like your zoldx
your netros and your freaks sisters but
for the most part Togashi well and truly
Embraces a more realistic approach to
characters and no matter what the case
turns out to be I look forward to seeing
more from all of the above